la mia storia inizia qui in questo
paesino nel cuore della sardegna che
famoso per un sito nuragico risalente
all'età del bronzo che indica che il
borgo era popolato finat già da 3500
anni fa ed è anche noto per la presenza
di grandi quantità di greggio il
pecorino buono se questo che vedete
nella foto qua è il mio omonimo nonché
mio cugino ciriaco gol di che come tanti
nel mio paese ha deciso di fare
l'allevatore in realtà anch'io potevo
fare il pastore come diciamo dalle mie
parti
se non che durante gli anni liceali
nacque me una forte passione per
l'astronomia e l'universo un po e
soprattutto grazie a questi due libri
che trovai per caso nello nella
biblioteca del mio liceo scientifico da
allora il primo è un best seller di
stephen hawking dal big bang ai buchi
neri breve storia del tempo e l'altro
forse un po meno noto e di stile wine
bar premio nobel per la fisica nel 79 i
primi tre minuti che descrive in estremo
dettaglio l'origine dell'universo in
particolare i primi tre minuti dopo il
big bang dal primo centesimo di secondo
dove si formano tutte le particelle
elementari che compongono l'universo
ora vi devo dire che quando lessi questo
libro rimasi completamente sconcertato
che si sapesse così tanto di qualcosa
che su tempi scala umani e pochissimo e
soprattutto qualcosa che è accaduto a 13
miliardi di anni fa quindi pensare
questa cosa è molto [ __ ] io ne voglio
far parte e quindi la maturò in me
la decisione di studiare fisica e di
contribuire a dare risposte alle domande
più ambiziose fondamentali che il genere
umano si possa fare da dove vengono
tutte le cose e quindi sa da dove viene
l'universo
ora la storia di buchi neri nasce 80
anni prima nel 1915 una allora anonimo
impiegato dell'ufficio brevetti di berna
pubblica una teoria rivoluzionaria sulla
gravità la gravità e la forza che domina
l'universo è il presupposto di questa
teoria era che in presenza di materia
spazio e tempo curvano su se stessi per
cui anche la luce non segue una
traiettoria rettilinea ma seguono
traiettoria la traiettoria e la
curvatura dello spazio questa congettura
fu corroborata con un osservazione
pochissimi anni dopo nel 1919 da parte
della storia americana ed in tono
durante un'eclissi di sole ed allora
einstein diventò l'icona popolare che
tutti conosciamo però la nostra storia
ha un altro eroe molto meno noto di
einstein che calcio acd un astronomo e
matematico tedesco che si trovava al
fronte nel 1916 e qualche mese dopo la
pubblicazione via installi arrivo chissà
come un manoscritto e lui si mise a
risolvere le sue equazioni
ora non so voi però io la mattina di
solito prima di due caffè non riesco a
far niente
immaginatevi farci durante la guerra che
gli volano sopra la testa di colpi
d'artiglieria tu non si mette a fare
della matematica e la fa anche bene
perché scopre una soluzione estrema all
equazione di einstein scopre che quando
compri mete abbastanza matera in un
volume molto piccolo
la curvatura dello spazio bembo diventa
così grande che niente può tornare
indietro e la materia cade
inesorabilmente in un punto quindi svar
ci trova matematicamente l'orizzonte
degli eventi e la singolarità al centro
in pratica scopre per la prima volta un
buco nero
ovviamente questa è un'astrazione
matematica quindi la questione che ci
possiamo chiedere se i buchi neri
esistano veramente nella realtà
ovviamente per definizione niente può
scappare da un buco nero
quindi sono completamente sicuri quindi
non li possiamo vedere direttamente però
ne possiamo vedere gli effetti che hanno
sull'ambiente circostante per che
esercitano un campo gravitazionale norme
questo video che vi sto mostrando è un
viaggio verso il centro della nostra
galassia dove abbiamo utilizzato dei
telescopi ottici per seguire il
movimento
di una trentina di stelle che sembrano
muoversi a una velocità molto elevata
attorno a un punto dove apparentemente
non c'è niente almeno otticamente un
punto oscuro
ci sono volute circa vent'anni di misure
molto accurate per seguire queste orbite
e alla fine abbiamo misurato che per far
muovere queste trenta stelle intorno a
una regione molto piccola ci serve
qualcosa come 4 milioni di volte la
massa del sole
questa è la prova principe che al centro
della nostra galassia c'è un mostro buco
nero di 4 milioni di masse solari
questa è la nostra galassia ma
ovviamente potete immaginare possiamo
estrapolare che anche per altre galassie
valga la stessa cosa e abbiamo delle
altre prove indirette
ora è vero che finora non avevamo mai
visto uno avevamo solo visto delle
conseguenze indirette però ci potremmo
chiedere se potessimo vederlo che
sembianze avrebbe un buco nero
in effetti questa non è una domanda
nuova già nel 1979 ciampi e illuminante
fa i primi conti le prime simulazioni al
computer e ci regala la prima
visualizzazione di un buco nero per
mettere le cose in contesto e jean
pierre luminet utilizza un vecchio
computer e ibm a scade perforate per
fare i suoi conti e dopo di che
all'epoca non esistevano di software
grafici e non esistevano delle stampanti
per cui quello che fece è
scrupolosamente disegnare a mano e sui
risultati di segno qualcosa come 10 mila
punti a penna e inchiostro
non so voi però questa per me è una
grande rappresentazione di connubio tra
scienza e arte
ovviamente adesso possiamo fare molto
meglio possiamo fare delle simulazioni
molto più sofisticate possiamo fare dei
filmati è questo che vi mostro qua
mostra la alla griglia dello spaziotempo
curvata per la presenza del buco nero e
i raggi dorati rappresentano radiazione
della materia che sta intorno al buco
nero e cerca di caderci nel fare questo
aumenta tantissimo la temperatura per
cui era già tantissimo
è quello che succede che quando passa
vicino all orizzonte degli eventi
i raggi scompaiono e l'effetto è quello
di per un osservatore di vedere
proiettata
un'ombra che è la proiezione
dell'orizzonte degli eventi questa è
quella che chiamiamo ombra di un buco
nero e questo è quello che ci siamo
messi in testa di fotografare con
l'evento raison tedesco ora direi di
lasciare il mondo delle simulazioni vi
voglio portare in un viaggio verso il
cosmo
in particolare un viaggio verso un vero
buco nero e per fare questo viaggio
partiamo dal deserto di atacama nelle
ande cilene dove ho speso tantissimo
tempo osservando e ci dirigiamo verso la
costellazione della vergine perché
sappiamo la esiste una galassia
massiccia la galassia più massiccia del
sistema del del sistema locale anche se
poi si trova 555 milioni di anni luce da
noi non proprio così vicina perché
praticamente per cui abbiamo delle prove
indirette della presenza di un buco nero
supermassiccio e questo viene dalla da
questa immagine dei getti relativistici
che viaggiano alla velocità prossima a
quella della luce molto energetici per
anni li abbiamo osservati alle soluzioni
sempre più alte
finché alla fine li ventura e un tedesco
non ci ha regalato l'immagine di quello
che sta al centro di questa galassia un
buco nero di 6.5 masse e miliardi di
masse solari e questa signori signore è
la prima immagine che l'umanità ha fatto
di un buco nero
[Applauso]
grazie grazie mille
anche noi abbiamo avuto una reazione
simile quando l'abbiamo vista per la
prima volta ora nel tempo che mi rimane
vi vorrei raccontare un pochino come ci
siamo arrivati a questa immagine ho
diviso la descrizione in tre fasi
allora la prima fase come astronomi
quando dobbiamo risolvere un problema di
una o studiano il sistema
la prima cosa che facciamo identificare
le caratteristiche tecniche del sud
dello strumento che ci serve è una
caratteristica principale è il potere ed
esecutivo o risoluzione angolare la
capacità di distinguere i due oggetti
nel nel cielo e quello che risulta e che
ovviamente più grande il telescopio
maggiore questo potere esecutivo e più
sono i dettagli che è riuscita a vedere
della vostra fonte celeste
ora quello che risulta è che i buchi nei
sono così piccoli che ci servirebbe un
telescopio delle dimensioni della terra
ovviamente non l'abbiamo costruita
altrimenti ve ne sarete accorti anche
voi però abbiamo usato una tecnica che
si basa su una rete di radiotelescopi
molto più piccoli dell'ordine 10 30
metri di diametro li facciamo osservare
insieme combiniamo i dati simuliamo al
computer un telescopio delle dimensioni
della terra
questo è in soldoni diventa horizon
telescope
quindi abbiamo telescopi e in diversi
continenti abbiamo la spagna
abbiamo le hawaii abbiamo l'arizona
abbiamo un telescopio in messico
ne abbiamo uno anche nel polo sud enel
nel deserto di atacama in cile è la
ragione per cui questa tecnica funziona
anche se abbiamo pochissimi telescopi è
che la terra gira e quindi cambia la
posizione di questi telescopi come visti
dalla sorgente celeste come vi ho
mostrato nel nel video che avete appena
visto che può servire anche a ricordare
che la terra in effetti è rotonda
nel caso ce ne fosse bisogno
[Applauso]
una volta che avevamo il nostro network
la nostra rete di telescopi pronti me
abbiamo formato delle squadre e ci siamo
recati ad ognuno di questi siti dei
monti per fare le osservazioni questo è
successo nel nell'aprile del 2017
come potete vedere diverse squadre e che
sono recate in spagna che sono recate
alla white in messico
non c'è una foto di quelle al polo sud
non so se perché erano troppo
infreddoliti comunque la foto fuori
quelli non l'hanno fatta invece al
deserto comunque non c'è problema è
questo sono io in cile con la mia
squadra e questo è il posto dove in
effetti ho passato tantissime noti negli
ultimi anni osservando per questo
progetto ed altri progetti
sembra di stare su marte non ci sono
forme di vita eccetto astronomi
ovviamente in visibilio perché ci sono
dei cieli bellissimi e si possono fare
delle osservazioni è impossibile da fare
in altre in altre parti
e in effetti quando si stato sotto il
cielo del cile è una sensazione mistica
di una delle cose che mi manca di più la
visione del cielo stellato dal dal
deserto comunque bellezze del cile a
parte a questo punto abbiamo i dati
quindi eravamo pronti per fare la foto
però non immaginate che sia qualcosa
così semplice come sviluppare un
negativo
ci sono voluti due anni di analisi dati
e adesso vi spiegherò in pochi minuti
cosa abbiamo fatto e in particolare
quindi una volta che registriamo tutti i
dati li registriamo in dischi rigidi le
mettiamo su aerei e li portiamo a un
centro di correlazione dove c'è un
supercomputer che combina i dati dai
diversi telescopi
ora vi ho detto che li abbiamo messi in
un aeroplano e la ragione
e che non si possono trasmettere su
internet perché il volume di dati enorme
registriamo una velocità che di 32
gigabit per secondo
quindi se non sapete cosa questo vuol
dire più o meno un film in hd su netflix
per secondo quindi abbastanza veloce
produciamo qualcosa come 500 terabyte di
dati per telescopio
quindi in realtà l'unità di misura che
usiamo e petabyte è un produciamo 4
petabyte di dati per per sessione
osservativa qualcosa tipo mezza
tonellate di dati che sono mostrati
nella foto qua e quindi non c'è internet
che tenga alla fine se mettete tanti
hard disk sul sulla stiva di un aereo
battete tutto l'internet del del mondo
quindi questa è la la frontiera ultima
della banda larga
[Applauso]
ora dopo che corriamo i dati li passiamo
a un team di calibrazione dove cerchiamo
il debole segnale che ci viene dal
telescope e lu ripuliamo da tutte le
imperfezioni strumentale anche dagli
effetti atmosferici
è un lavoro certosino e richiede grande
esperienza una volta che ripuliamo tutti
i dati li passiamo al team di immagini e
praticamente convertiamo il segnale
registrato dal telescopio in emissione
di radiazione da parte della sorgente
quelle in pratica facciamo un immagine e
vi devo dire che io faccio parte di
questo di questo team di grandi
scienziati di grande esperienza 50
scienziati hanno lavorato sodo per due
anni per fare questo studio qua perché
abbiamo fatto centinaia di controlli
incrociati avevamo diverse team che
lavoravano indipendentemente gruppi di
lavoro dei gruppi di controllo perché il
contro i test incrociati ci servivano
per prima di tutto convincere il noi e
poi convincere il resto del mondo che
quello che avevamo trovato era veramente
un risultato genuino e questo abbiamo
fatto ora vorrei spendere l'ultima parte
del mio seminario raccontandomi un
pochino facendo delle considerazioni su
quelle che sono le implicazioni di
questa scoperta allora direi che quello
che cambia ora è che buchi neri non sono
più un astrazione matematica una
soluzione un'equazione o anche
fantascienza sono oggetti reali
astrofisici che possiamo osservare con
dei telescopi e quindi li possiamo usare
come laboratori è la cosa più importante
è che tutto quello che abbiamo visto e
in accordo con le predizioni della
teoria di einstein quindi possiamo dire
che einstein aveva ragione
per ora perché ovviamente stiamo
lavorando a nuovi da abbiamo acquisito
nuovi dati e in acquisiremo di nodi di
altri e stiamo cercando di corroborare
la teoria in maniera ancora più rigorosa
quindi se non aver ragione per ora
almeno non aveva torto
quindi può dormire sonni tranquilli
anche se un po più con cui più un po più
preoccupato di come era nella foto
precedente
ora piuttosto che parlarvi delle
implicazioni astrofisiche di questa
scoperta che vorrei parlare vorrei
concentrarmi su quello delle
implicazioni sociologiche perché
questa è stata una scoperta storica che
è stata accolta da dalla comunità
scientifica astronomica ma anche
dall'opinione pubblica che ha dimostrato
un entusiasmo quasi inaspettato
il giorno dopo del dell'annuncio siamo
rimasti un po colpiti che tutti i
quotidiani principali nazionali
internazionali dal dall'europa al
giappone agli stati uniti alla cina
avevano l'immagine nella prima pagina e
quindi c'è qualcosa che va al di là
della scienza forse perché sebbene tutti
sebbene pochissimi capiscano la
matematica la fisica insita nei buchi
neri
tutti ne capiscono il simbolismo come
delle bocche spalancate cosmiche che si
mangiano tutto quello che passa in tono
anno fa lo fanno uscire più niente
ovviamente sai che hai colto nel segno
quando una scoperta scientifica porta
dopo l'annuncio a imperversare di me
messi irriverenti in rete alcune anche
molto politicamente scorretti
però quello vuol dire una cosa che buchi
neri sono diventati un'icona culturale
oppure c'è qualcosa di più profondo
forse i buchi neri sono il mondo
dell'universo di ricordarci che c'è un
limite fondamentale alla nostra capacità
di conoscere perché oltre l'orizzonte
degli eventi non possiamo più andare
quindi quelle limite la frontiera ultima
di conoscenze e quindi questo è un po
l'emblema della condizione umana
oppure c'è qualcosa di ancora più umano
che è quella il piacere è l'emozione
della sfida del mission impossible
perché c'è una novità che un buco nero
non si può vedere è invece in noi ci
abbiamo provato lo stesso e ci avevano
detto che sarebbe stato necessario avere
un telescopio delle dimensioni della
terra e noi non l'abbiamo costruito per
ora abbiamo simulato e per farlo
funzionare
abbiamo costruito una squadra di persone
motivate dallo stesso obiettivo
scientifico e la squadra era prima
piccola e poi è cresciuta in realtà
tante piccole squadre si sono messi
insieme piccole squadre che prima
competevano
e poi si sono messi insieme in una
grande collaborazione internazionale
perché da soli non ce l'avrei mai fatta
e adesso siamo 250 membri
che vivono in 20 paesi lavano i 60
istituti diversi
se vogliamo costruire un telescopio
globale bisogna avere un team globale e
quindi noi dell'evento horizon telescope
ci siamo serviti del uno dei più grandi
misteri dell'universo per come fonte di
ispirazione per raggiungere un obiettivo
che ci avevano detto era impossibile
e se questa idea che ha motivato noi io
spero che il nostro risultato possa
motivare tutti quanti a raggiungere
sempre nuovi obiettivi frequanti
impossibili e si sente
grazie